whoopi goldberg has been suspended for
two weeks from the view following this
controversial comment she made on
monday's episode and let's be truthful
about it because the holocaust isn't
about race it's about man's inhumanity
to man et can confirm that the 66 year
old co-host will not appear on the
daytime talk show effective immediately
in light of her suspension kim godwin
president of abc news released this
statement quote i am suspending whoopi
goldberg for two weeks for her wrong and
hurtful comments while whoopi has
apologized i've asked her to take time
to reflect and learn about the impact of
her comments ahead of releasing that
statement godwin sent a note to abc
staffers regarding whoopi's comments
that read in part quote the culture at
abc news is one that is driven kind
inclusive respectful and transparent
whoopi's comments do not align with
those values the truth of the matter is
we are all adults and we know how to
behave at a table just hours before abc
announced the suspension former the view
co-host megan mccain spoke out against
how the show handled whoopi's comments
in a column for dailymail.com megan
wrote quote instead of half apologies in
bringing in experts in the anti-semitism
space
maybe dedicate an entire hot topic
segment to discussing why what was said
was so deeply offensive and dangerous
megan added that in the world of media
there are people who will never face the
same ramifications and repercussions
that others will writing quote there's a
double triple and even quadruple
standard if you are conservative megan
noted on twitter that she hates
commenting on her old employer because
she has moved on but that she's an
activist against anti-semitism and it's
a big part of her life for context here
is a topic that led to whoopi's comments
and if you teach a white kid what
happened to his his friend who happens
to be black it all started when the
panel was discussing a tennessee school
district's decision to ban the graphic
novel mouse which is about the holocaust
personally i'm shocked because you know
given the story of mouse i'm i'm
surprised that that's what
that's what made you uncomfortable the
fact that there was some nudity and uh
i mean it's it's about the holocaust the
killing of six million people but that
didn't that didn't bother you but the
the naked i'm not sure that they don't
use the naked part as a kind of a canard
to throw you off from
the fact that they might like history
that makes white maybe they look bad but
as whoopi continues debating the topic
some of her co-hosts don't seem to agree
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no
it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about what is it because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy the oscar winner
immediately received a backlash on
social media leading her to apologize on
twitter monday evening whoopi writes
quote on today's show i said the
holocaust is not about race but about
man's inhumanity to men i should have
said it is about both as jonathan
greenblatt from the anti-defamation
league shared quote the holocaust was
about the nazi systemic annihilation of
the jewish people who they deemed to be
an inferior race i stand corrected the
actress adds that jewish people around
the world have always had her support
and that will never change quote i'm
sorry for the hurt i have caused it
spoke to the egot winner ahead of the
views 25th season and she said this
about the panelists having different
opinions doing what we're supposed to be
doing this is our this is our gig and
this is
you know
our our uh
our gift from
the world because not everybody gets to
have an opinion not everybody gets to
say this is what i think and here's why
and let's talk about this this is a
really great job it's a really great job
and i'm going to speak for us but i
think we're lucky as
for hell
[Music]